radio canada me demande de retourner en
ukraine jusqu'à qui oeuvre à partir de
montréal c'est loin d'être simple
premières étapes d'abord se rendre en
neuf ans c'est un [ __ ] on est interdit
aux bonnes voiles vers qui aiment encore
donc il faut se rendre en pologne
varsovie ça fait 14 heures environ qu'on
a quitté le québec vient ensuite il ya
des heures de route a fait entre
varsovie et qui est bien plus de 900
kilomètres de routes théoriquement ça
peut prendre dix heures mais avec la
frontière traversions c'est pas comme
maintenant se reprend on est arrêté à
quelques mètres la frontière quinzaine
une vingtaine de véhicules devant nous
on en a peut-être pour une heure une
heure et demie attentes qui profite ni
en arrière de nous il ya énormément de
gens regardez ça nous a pris 7 heures
venir jusqu à lviv pour aller jusqu à
kiev maintenant il reste encore 8 qui
rend le voyage compliqué c'est
l'approvisionnement en essence regardez
la file de véhicules et gens qui
attendent plus d'une heure pour avoir
quelques litres d'essence on peut pas
faire le plein si voilà kiev enfin après
des heures et des heures de route un peu
de repos maintenant c'est le travail qui
commence